this is an experimental helicopter
specially fitted out with armor plate
and heavily armed it is on its way to
neutralize a landing zone in the central
highlands of South Vietnam where shortly
troops of the 1st Air Cav will be going
in approaching the target a shower of
2.75 rockets fired from two rocket pods
scours the area now on top of the target
the helicopters gonna recruits up with
caliber 50 machine-gun fire raking the
area from one end to the other returning
to its base at on K the big ch-47 a
Chinook lands on one of the maintenance
area pads the program to evaluate these
four and a half million dollar choppers
is being conducted from here at the pad
an evaluation board officer discusses
the crafts performance with the flight
engineer guns agogo is the name given to
this special aviation detachment and
it's experimental program which includes
daily maintenance in addition to
mechanical maintenance there is
electronic upkeep on items like the
servo amplifier which controls the
choppers grenade launcher system 2562
pounds of armor plates protect the
Chinook vital component areas an armor
specialist checks the installation
before every flight a total of
thirty-eight 2.75 Rockets are fired from
two pods a 40-millimeter grenade
launcher mounted in a ball turret on the
helicopters nose fires 700 rounds in one
loading there are five calibre 50
machine guns on this ship two on each
side and one ass with these weapons
systems plus 2 20 millimeter cannon the
experimental machines offer the
firepower of 8 fully equipped hu 1b
gunships a scramble has been called and
the members of the Chinook seven-man
crew rushed to their station
the mission calls for an air strike
against an enemy automatic weapons
position 16 kilometers northeast of
Keaney on fire team missions are only
part of the support work done by the
special aircraft only moments from the
target one chopper flies security while
the other makes its first pass below now
in action the number to ship unleashes a
rocket attack repeated hits mark the
enemy position dropping down and passing
directly over the target the big chopper
serves as a shooting platform for the
five machine gunners enemy ground fire
pelts the ship like to infuriated
bumblebees the ch-47 A's come back again
protected by their armor which can turn
away calibre 50 fire the big ships pound
the enemy with massive firepower
next time around there is no resistance
from the ground a gaping hole in the
cabin ceiling attest to the enemy ground
fire encounter during this mission the
evaluation of the effectiveness of these
armored and armed helicopters continues
despite hits from enemy ground fire the
fortified choppers are establishing a
remarkable record in Vietnam
in mid-september troops of the u.s. 1st
Infantry Division discover a large cache
of rice in the Vietcong stronghold of
Binh Duong Province situated near like a
some 48 kilometers north of Saigon the
captured rice weighs nearly 12 tons a
Huey is used to remove the rice from the
small clearing to an open field where a
cargo chopper can take on the load the
captured rice will be airlifted to been
cut 8 kilometers to the south and
they're distributed to the relocated
Vietnamese refugees the Huey begins the
short haul out to an open field at this
dried up rice paddy a Chinook cargo
helicopter can land to pick up the
entire rice fine and fly it to ben COK
the Huey makes several trips bringing
the rice out troops handling the
transfer camp here overnight next day
the Chinook arrives with such gusto that
the troopers of the big red one are sent
running helter-skelter wind from the
huge rotors flattens shelters and rub
some people the wrong way the incident
is soon forgotten however and the
arduous task of loading begins to speed
things up a bag brigade is formed and
the hundred pound sacks are soon loaded
aboard the cargo copter security patrols
are called in as soon as the loading is
completed and the Chinook prepares to
take off in spite of a ponderous load of
grain the chopper lifts off easily and
heads for ben COK
minutes later the village comes into
view and the Chinook touches down the
people are waiting eagerly word has
spread that the Americans are going to
distribute free rice and there is no
shortage of Vietnamese men to help
unload the aircraft from the stockpile
outside the helicopter the bags are
transferred one more time to a waiting
truck since the rice is now being turned
over to the Vietnamese refugees the
handling and dividing is being
supervised by a Vietnamese Army officer
as the moment of distribution draws near
the Arvind officer expresses thanks on
the part of the villagers for the gift
and some of the handing out of the
captured enemy rice begins each person
is given a five-pound bag of the
precious drain to the Vietnamese rice is
the most important staple in their diet
the rice here being distributed in the
continuing civic action program in
Vietnam could have sustained the enemy
soldiers in the field for a long time
now the Communist PO is not only denied
but the food is helping to bring about a
stronger tyre friendship between the
American soldier and the people of South
Vietnam
in the bung saw an area approximately 80
kilometers north of kin yan members of
the 1st air cavalry division are engaged
in operation fair their mission to
search and sweep the rice fields and
surrounding areas where villagers are
forced to donate a portion of their crop
to the Viet Cong the rice is hidden in
secluded jungle areas then under cover
of darkness the Viet Cong move in and
carry off the grain rice found by the
troops is taken out by helicopter to
division where it is distributed to the
most needy villagers are assembled for
questioning VC suspects are separated
from the others and are held for more
intensive interrogation the company
medic helps to make friends by treating
villagers for colds insect bites or
other minor ailments
no contact is made with the enemy during
daylight hours however continuous sniper
fire is encountered during the night and
early morning a call for aid for the men
who have been hit by sniper fire brings
the medics the wounded are evacuated by
helicopter to the 15th medical
evacuation battalion approximately 40
kilometers to the south here the wounded
are given additional treatment by
doctors the more serious casualties are
then taken to the 85th evacuation
hospital in qingyuan
on 3 September this caribou aircraft
crashed on takeoff falling into a small
village at the end of the Special Forces
runway at dong tray damage to the
village itself was considerable men of
the 17th aviation battalion prepared the
craft for recovery they righted the
fuselage unloaded its cargo and took off
the wings these were all removed to the
salvage yard at kean jaan bhai chinook
helicopter all but the fuselage this
needed something bigger to move it on
the 15th one of the first calves flying
cranes was called in hovering from an
altitude of 75 feet so as to eliminate
further damage to the village from
propwash a cable was lowered the
fuselage attached and removed only a few
straw roofs were messed up during the
operation but the crane was fired upon
by snipers as it departed
when Greece Germany 15 September a team
from psychological operations 10th
Special Forces Group prepares for an
airdrop infiltration exercise the
equipment being rigged for the drop is
part of a complete set consisting of a
tape recorder amplifier and speaker
system
in an airmobile van propaganda leaflets
are prepared for distribution behind the
enemy lines plates are photographed and
then engraved on an aluminum master
which will be used to print the leaflets
the jump team is led by the company
commander first lieutenant john w
pershing grandson of former General John
J Pershing a helicopter swiftly carries
the team to its destination for the
operation which would normally d conduct
it under cover of darkness lieutenant
Pershing is the first man out and he is
quickly followed by other team members
and equipment the descent is effective
and on target the lowering lines are set
out for the equipment
on the ground the team quickly regroups
and sets up the equipment for immediate
operation with the amplifier and speaker
systems operational and the tape
recorder spinning the senate pershing
tests the complete set up the team moves
out on the next leg of its mission a
hit-and-run operation to disseminate
information calculated to disorient the
enemy
as brigadier general robert r linville's
one star flag is taken down for the last
time moving crews dismantled the VHF
antennas which served as such an
important link in the island wide
inter-american peace force communication
system in the Dominican Republic these
Brazilian marine and US army units
represent the last of the five nations
peace forced to disband following the
inauguration of President Joaquin
Balaguer on june first unhand was the
Honorable nascimento da Silva Brazilian
ambassador to the Dominican Republic the
ia PF's commander Brazilian general all
of a salvar oh da Silva Braga adds his
own farewell a member of Brazilian and
American officers are decorated by rear
admiral some pile Fernandez shown here
awarding the Brazilian Navy medal for
distinguished service to general Bravo
and Colonel Frederick field and the Tom
andheri Medal of Merit to US Army
Colonel Herbert herb Brazil among the
first to respond with men for the I APF
sending a full battalion to this
Caribbean nation is among the last to
leave generals braja and Linville wish
them well at the Harbor of santo domingo
another contingent embarks by ship for
real unable to attend the awards
ceremony earlier general Linville is
decorated on board later general braja
arrives at San Isidro airfield where US
Air Force colonel robert l demic
presents him with a plaque on behalf of
the Tactical Air Command US ambassador
the Honorable John crimmins extends his
own best wishes and the general boards a
c-123 for the trip to Puerto Rico from
where he'll begin the long flight back
to Brazil the following day
general Linville joins the last members
of the 82nd Airborne Division for the
trip to Pope Air Force Base by 10 45 his
plane was airborne by noon the last of
the c-130s had deported the iaps had
ceased to exist
at a base six kilometers from Santo
Domingo several teams of us advisers
working under the military aid and
assistance program our training members
of the Dominican first Brigade the
object is to build the brigade into an
elite highly trained infantry force
several officers are assigned to
instruct the men of the first in basic
unit tactics from the squad level on up
weaponry training includes crew drills
on a wide assortment of light weapons
such as the 30 caliber machine gun
riot control and the use of gas for
dispersal is an important part of the
counter guerrilla tactical training here
lieutenant a Leo Camacho coaches a mob
dispersal formation us training of
Dominican forces was begun by the 82nd
airborne while on duty in the Dominican
Republic its success led to the present
expanded program elsewhere on the base a
team from the 8th Special Forces is
training a nucleus mortar platoon for
the brigade the men are learning to use
the 4.2 inch mortar later they
themselves will serve as instructors for
the rest of the army practical
application begins with the installation
of a pneumatic firing device this
enables practice firing and the aiming
of small dummy show
the men are drilled over and over again
until he can set up their weapon in a
matter of seconds the training program
culminates at the sierra pre-arranged
where the crews get a chance to aim and
fire live shells at a variety of targets
hits are plotted on the training board
at the simulated fire control center and
the results relayed to the crew
another phase of assistance is the
improvement of supply at first Brigade
quartermaster headquarters us sergeant
Manuel Lauren Cole is conducting an OJT
program Dominican NCOs work with the
sergeant for three months gaining
experience in modern supply methods
before returning to their brigade
assignment in a related project Special
Forces captain Richard Thompson is
working with the Dominican second
engineer battalion the object of this
operation is to establish a better
maintenance and supply system at one
time more than eighty-five percent of
the unit's vehicles were deadlines but
since the new procedures began the
figure has shrunk to fifteen percent
despite its problems the battalion has
been initiating civic action projects
all over the Republic one such project
is the construction of a road near
christoval 250 kilometers from Santo
Domingo torrential rains often wash out
the existing roads and it is hoped that
in all weather road will encourage the
reopening of salt and gypsum mines in
the area thus providing employment for
the people the nearest source of
drinking water for the three thousand
residents of crystal ball is more than 5
kilometers away and each day during
construction the engineers truck in
thousands of gallons of purified water
for the local family in both military
and civic projects the US aid and
assistance program in the Dominican
Republic is continuing successfully
the XM 561 articulated one and a quarter
ton truc known affectionately as the
gamma goat begins the water phase of its
testing off the coast of Virginia it was
soon recommended that a bilge pump be
installed it drives up the slippery ramp
of an LST and back again into the water
the freeboard operation of this
experimental vehicle when swimming with
or without a rated load had a marked
tendency towards pitching therefore it
was further recommended that these
operations be confined to calmer waters
at Camp Wallace the testing continues
over a series of off-road traversals
through highly irregular terrain behind
the XM 561 is the three-quarter ton m37
cargo truck being used as the standard
of comparison after completing each run
these shifting and conditions of cargoes
hauled were carefully inspected the UL
42 Sandpiper here being tested for its
maneuverability was developed to provide
effective support for today's highly
mobile army
this ultra light high flotation forklift
has a 4,000 pound plus load capacity
here it goes through the highway
adaptability test course at Fort Lee at
high speeds if noticeably oversteered a
hazardous operating condition afterwards
it is hoisted aboard a landing barge to
test blocking and tie down methods to
appraise its cargo handling
characteristics the UL 42 moves and
storage supplies under conditions
simulating logistical operations on a
backup course it drives up the steep
incline of a sea 124 and out the
fuselage overhang of a Chinook
helicopter however the driver has to do
a bit of fancy tucking the sandpiper
still in the developmental stage
on august twenty-first 39 teams
representing 12 member nations met in
Munich to hold the 19th annual military
competition of the inter-allied
Confederation of reserve officers this
year's US teams coached by lieutenant
Richard M Hubbard attend the opening
services at the tomb of Germany's
Unknown Soldier the flags are raised at
the ferrocene hand exhibition grounds
and will fly throughout the five days of
the competition arriving at newburgh
German air force base general Lyman LM
nitor supreme Allied commander europe
joins other NATO dignitaries at the
competition this US team awaits its turn
on the rifle and pistol range they get
the feel of the Uzi 9-millimeter
submachine gun the p38 Walter and the
cetme 7.62 rifle at the verbal Reich's
command of military sports ground
lieutenant Hubbard and major Alexander
Jerry used three telescopic lenses to
sight in on an azimuth before setting
out on their cross country event
this is a 12 kilometer run by map
compass and photo the US which has won
this competition for the past four years
has a trio of three-man teams entered
the scoring in all events is based upon
accuracy and speed much the same as is
used in the Olympics for the decathlon
and pentathlon two events down two to go
a welcomed pause but for some teams that
going gets wet the finals of the pool
and obstacle trials are held at the
Prince Asian kaserne in the ground
course there are 20 such obstacles to
overcome ladders to scamper up and over
barriers to hurdle and more barriers and
still more barriers
and finally dirt and ropes to grope
through on the following day with their
generals in attendance our teams
participate in the utility swim wearing
German military fatigue which when wet
way an additional 25 pounds according to
lieutenant Hubbard this cuts a good 10
to 15 seconds off the men's time
prizes are to be awarded at a banquet
and ball held that night at the
fashionable Regina Palace Hotel and top
prize goes to the US
Oh